Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an American crime comedy film
called “Little Man.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Calvin Simms is a convicted jewelry thief serving
prison time in Chicago. In the opening scene,
he orders a fellow inmate to count the number
of pull-ups for him. By the looks of it,
Calvin is a tough guy, respected by all the
inmates. On the day Calvin is let free, he walks
out of the prison and reveals that he suffers
from dwarfism and is barely three feet tall.
His friend and fellow thief Percy picks him
up, accidentally hitting him with the car door
while he is at it. Percy doesn’t waste time before
informing Calvin of their next heist. A dangerous
gang leader Walken has appointed Percy to steal
a diamond from a jewelry shop for a hundred
thousand dollars. Calvin, who thoroughly enjoyed
his time in prison, doesn't care about being
convicted again. Hence, he accepts the deal.
Following that, we are introduced to the Edward
couple. The husband Darryl is a family man who
wants to have a child as soon as possible. His
wife Vanessa is also keen on starting a family but
wants to prioritize work for the next few years.
The couple is at a restaurant where Vanessa
says she has good news to share with Darryl.
Not giving her a chance to disclose what exactly
the news is, Darryl announces that she is
pregnant to the rest of the restaurant. Everyone
claps and cheers for the couple while Vanessa
embarrassingly claims that it is not the case.
The good news is that she got promoted at work.
A disheartened Darryl congratulates her
which doesn’t go unnoticed to Vanessa.
Recently, there has been a rift in the couple’s
relationship because of their differences.
Somewhere else, Calvin and Percy go to a jewelry
shop to steal the diamond. Percy puts Calvin in
a bag and takes him inside. While he distracts
the store manager, Calvin swiftly goes under
the display and steals the diamond. Everything
goes according to the plan until a chihuahua
chases after Calvin and gets inside the bag with
him. The dog owner freaks out, after hearing it
bark from inside Percy’s bag. As the burglars
run away, the store manager notices the missing
diamond and calls the police. Suddenly, Percy
comes to a halt because he feels a sharp pain
in his leg. Calvin thinks he was shot but it
turns out that he pulled a muscle. The duo runs
into a convenience store to hide while still being
followed by the police. Coincidently, the Edward
couple is also at the store, arguing as usual.
In a moment of panic, Calvin puts the diamond in
Vanessa’s bag to not be caught with it.
A while later, the policemen go away,
thinking that they lost the thieves. After that,
Calvin and Percy follow the couple to their home.
In the next scene, we are introduced to Vanessa’s
father, Pops. He is living with the couple because
of his old age. Darryl and Pop hardly ever get
along because pop thinks Darryl is unworthy of
his daughter. Even now, he comments how Darryl
cannot get his daughter pregnant because he
has “no bullets in his chamber”. Vanessa settles
their argument and is definite that she will only
have a baby when she is ready. Outside, Percy
gets ready with a gun to get the diamond back
but Calvin insists they need to think of a better
plan. A lady pushing a stroller gives Percy
a genius idea. The next day, Calvin shaves his
beard and gets inside a basket to pose as a baby.
Percy keeps him outside the couple’s door and runs
away, hoping that they will take Calvin in.
When Darryl comes outside,
Calvin imitates a baby’s noise
and the man buys into the obviously staged act.
They bring the baby inside and try to change
his diapers. Although what’s under his diapers
surprises the family, they dismiss it. Initially,
the family calls the child services but is
informed that the offices won’t open until after
the weekend. Their second option is to take the
baby to a doctor to check if he is doing alright.
The doctor finds sketchy things like a tattoo
on the baby’s arm and a surgery scar. However,
he thinks the child is overall normal
and lets the couple take him home.
When Darryl and Vanessa are busy
discussing what they should do next,
Calvin bolts outside with Vanessa’s purse.
But a policeman catches him on the way
and hands him back to Vanessa. The baby calls
her mama which melts her heart so she decides
to keep him until they find his parents.
Somewhere else, Percy meets the gangster Walken
who suspects they have fled with his diamond.
He threatens Percy to get it back in twenty-four
hours or else, both he and Calvin will be
dead by the twenty-fifth hour. Back at home,
little Calvin startles Pops who mistakes him
for Chucky. Pops clearly doesn’t like him
and his presence in the house but he is
ready to compromise for his daughter.
That evening, Vanessa and Darryl hold a party to
officially welcome Calvin to the family. A couple
of their friends come over who at first glance
think Calvin is an ugly child. One friend tries
to be nice and calls him adorable in a national
geography kind of way. Although Calvin is acting
like a baby, he cannot suppress his manly urges.
He holds onto one of Vanessa’s friends and tries
grabbing her. When she leans down to give him a
goodbye kiss, he even forcefully makes out with
her. The couple thinks it is weird but chooses to
ignore it. Later at night, Calvin tries getting
close to Vanessa on several occasions; first,
he cutely invites her to bathe with him, then,
he pushes her head when she tries to tickle
him. Before going to bed, the couple puts him
inside his crib and makes him fall asleep.
Calvin wakes up in the middle of the night and
finally decides to do the work that he was there
for. He jumps out of the crib and goes downstairs
to call Percy. While he is at it, Pops finds him
talking like an adult and is happy that he was
right about the big baby. Right then, Darryl also
wakes up but he doesn’t believe pop’s claims about
the kid. Darryl thinks Calvin is hungry and makes
him a bottle. He also sympathizes with the kid
and his presumably bad childhood. Calvin, who has
never had a father figure talk to him like that,
is touched by Darryl’s words.
A while later, Vanessa and Darryl get
steamy in bed. They feel slightly uncomfortable
because Calvin cannot stop staring at them. Still,
Darryl claims that the kid doesn’t know what is
going on and gets under the blankets. The next
morning, Vanessa wakes up with a magical glow and
compliments Darryl on his newfound skills in bed.
Darryl is confused because he didn’t do anything
new. Just then, Calvin is revealed to have climbed
on bed sometime at night. The couple doesn’t
think much of it and ends the conversation.
The following day, Vanessa goes to work leaving
Darryl responsible to take care of the child.
When he is busy, Calvin manages to get a hold of
the diamond from Vanessa’s purse. Now, he only has
to think of a way to escape the household without
making a big fuss. Later, Darryl brings Calvin to
a park for a father-son quality time. However, the
“quality” time is not fun for Darryl because the
kid hits him in the crotch several times. When no
one is looking, Percy arrives at the park and asks
Calvin for the diamond. But the parents notice
him and chase him away before he can get it.
The diamond is in the diaper bag that Darryl puts
in the car trunk. Calvin takes the opportunity to
run away with the entire car. A naive Darryl still
thinks that someone stole his car and his kid.
He hitchhikes in a lady’s vehicle who drives like
there is no tomorrow. By the end of the chase,
Darryl is sobbing, saying that the baby
is not worth the risk of driving with her.
A police car stops Calvin at last but believes
that the suspect ran away without the baby.
Somewhere else, Percy goes to the gangster with
a random diaper bag he picked up from the park
earlier. Walken digs into the bag but finds
dirty diapers instead of the diamond. Still,
the gangster gives Percy some more time to get
the real diamond. He secretly asks his henchmen
to follow him and kill both Percy and his partner
if they aren’t able to retrieve the rock.
The next day, Darryl and his friends take Calvin
to an ice hockey game. When no one is looking,
Calvin grabs the diamond from the diaper bag. As
Darryl turns to him, he quickly puts the rock in
his mouth and swallows it to not get caught. The
game goes well until Calvin catcalls a server and
gets Darryl in trouble. On returning home, the
couple puts Calvin to sleep and decides to throw
him a birthday party the following day. At the
party, Calvin is bored out of his mind. However,
when it is time to cut the cake, he gets emotional
because no one has ever shown him this much love.
He is genuinely thankful that he got parents who
take such great care of him. At the same time,
Pops is at a diner when he sees Calvin’s face
in the news. He finds out the kid is actually a
dwarf criminal and is ready to expose him. He
runs to the party and gives him a teddy bear
as a present. What Calvin doesn’t know is that
the teddy bear has a hidden camera inside.
After the birthday party, Calvin drinks a bottle
of laxatives to help him get the diamond out.
The plan works but Vanessa finds the diamond
while changing his diaper. She believes that
it is a surprise gift from her husband and jumps
up on top of him in excitement. Darryl tries to
explain that the diamond isn’t from him but
she doesn’t give him a chance to talk.
They go to dinner that night, leaving Pops
to babysit Calvin. After the couple leaves,
he pretends to play with Calvin and throws him
to the ground. Eventually, Calvin has to come
clean to him but he threatens pops to not tell
anyone. Meanwhile, in the restaurant, Vanessa
tells Darryl that she is ready to adopt Calvin and
make him their own. They excitedly return home,
only to find pops strangling Calvin. Horrified
by the action, they kick him out of the house
and take Calvin to his room. Before being
pulled away, pops tells his daughter to look
at the teddy because he knows everything.
Darryl checks the stuffed toy and finds out it
is actually a camera. He connects it to the TV
and discovers a recording of Calvin admitting
the truth. He immediately heads to the bedroom
only to find that Calvin has already run away.
In the following scene, Calvin and Percy are back
together celebrating that they got the diamond.
Percy reveals that the gangsters are after Darryl
and his family because they think the couple
stole the stone. Realizing that the family is in
danger, Calvin returns to help them. Meanwhile,
Vanessa leaves to look for her father. When Darryl
is alone, Walken and two of his henchmen come to
the house and hold him hostage. Just then,
Calvin arrives and pretends to be a child.
Because the henchmen underestimate him, he
manages to beat them up. At the same time,
Darryl fights Walken. The fight goes on for quite
a while before the police arrive at the scene.
They arrest the criminals and ask Darryl about the
kid. Darryl feels indebted to Calvin for coming
to help him, so he saves him from the police. They
are also informed that they will receive a hundred
thousand dollars for helping the police find the
diamond. When the two are left alone in the house,
Calvin thanks Darryl for everything and wishes him
farewell. But when he reaches outside, he starts
crying at the thought that he will never have a
family again. Darryl feels bad and is genuinely
sad that Calvin has to go. At last, he makes the
decision to keep Calvin as a family member.
In the ending scene, Calvin and pops are playing
with Vanessa’s newborn kid. To everyone’s
surprise, the kid looks exactly like Calvin.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.